اسرائيل ترفعوا حاله التاهب على الحدود
الشماليه بعد اسقاط مسيره يعتقد انها
ايرانيه
بعد رفع فاجنر العلم على مبنى اداره بخموت
اوكرانيا تؤكد انها ما زالت تسيطر على
المدينه
ولاول مره منذ سبع سنوات تدريبات كوريه
جنوبيه امريكيه يابانيه لمواجهه تهديدات
بيونج
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته اهلا بكم
الى هذه النشره نستهل مشاهدينا تفاصيل
النشره من اعلان اسرائيل لرفع حاله التاهب
امنيا وعسكريا على الحدود الشماليه بشقيها
السوري واللبناني رفعوا حاله التاهب هذه
جاءت غداه اسقاط مسيره يعتقد انها ايرانيه
فوق منطقه الحوله شمال طبريه في الجليل
وكان الجيش الاسرائيلي وكان الجيش
الاسرائيلي جمع حطام المسيره ليلا واوضح
انها كانت تحت تعقب دائم من مقاتلتين
مروحيه عسكريه
الجيش الاسرائيلي كان استدعى مروحيات
ومقاتلات حربيات تابعه له اثر رصد المسيره
التي تسللت من جهه الاراضي السوريه الى
داخل الاجواء الاسرائيليه وتم اسقاط
المسيره في منطقه مفتوحه فيما قدرت
التحقيقات الاوليه ان المسيره الايرانيه
الصنع وبحسب القناه الثانيه عشره او بحسب
القناه الثانيه عشره الاسرائيليه
اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه وفاه شاب
فلسطيني برصاص القوات الاسرائيليه خلال
اقتحامها حي المخفي في نابلس وافد مراسل
العربيه بوقوع اشتباكات واطلاق نار خلال
عمليه الاقتحام وذكرت وسائل اعلام
اسرائيليه انه تم اعتقال شابين اثنين خلال
مداهمه احد المباني بذريعه الاشتباه في
ضلوعهما بعمليه اطلاق النار الاخيره في
حواره
وفي تطورات العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا
اكد الجيش الاوكراني انه مازال يسيطر على
بخ موت الواقعه شرق اوكرانيا هذا التاكيد
جاء بعد اعلان مجموعه باجنر الروسيه
السيطره على المدينه بالمعنى القانوني
وقالت هيئه الاركان العامه الاوكرانيه ان
روسيا لم توقف هجماتها على بخموت وان
المدافعين الاوكرانيين يسيطرون على
المدينه وصدوا الكثير من الهجمات
وفي وقت سابق اعلنت مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه
سيطره على مبنى بلديه بخمو شرق اوكرانيا
من وجهه نظر قانونيه ولو حقائد فاجنر
يفغيني بالعلم الروسي من امام مبنى
البلديه قائلا انه تمت السيطره على بخموت
بالمعنى القانوني وان القوات الاوكرانيه
متمركزه في المناطق الغربيه
اليوم الثاني من ابريل بالتحديد الساعه
الحاديه عشره مساء خلفي مبنى اداره مدينه
باخموت هذا هو العلم الروسي كتب عليه
تحديدا للذكراه الطيبه لقد اخذنا مخموت من
وجهه نظر قانونيه قاده وحدات القوات
الروسيه الذين تولوا اداره المدينه والحيه
المركزيه باكمله سيرفعون الاعلام العدو ظل
في الاحياء الغربيه
اعلنت الرئاسه البولنديه ان الرئيس
الاوكراني
سيزور وارسو يوم الاربعاء المقبل في
الخامس من ابريل مضيفه انه سيلتقي
باللاجئين في ساحه قلعه العاصمه من جهته
اعلن مسؤول السياسه الدوليه في مكتب
الرئيس البولندي مارسين ان بلاده سلمت
عددا من مقاتلات
بواقع اربع مقاتلات قاذفه ما سيشكل اول
عمليه تسليم من قبل دوله عضو في حلف شمال
الاطلسي
نفت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه الضلوع في تفجير
احد المقاهي في سانت بطرسبرج وكانت
السلطات الروسيه اعلنت في وقت سابق ان
التفجير استهدف المراسل الحربي التابعه
لفاجنر فلادلين تتارسكي
مراسل عسكري روسي ومدون معروف فقد حياته
في تفجير احد المقاهي في مدينه سامبرسبرج
الروسيه حسب وزاره الداخليه لم تتبنى حتى
الان اي جهه مسؤوليه الانفجار كما لم تقدم
السلطات اي تفاصيل عما قالت ان سببه هو
قنبله كانت بحوزه احد رواد المقهى لكن
مقاطع ما قبل لحظات من التفجير اظهرت
تتارسكي وهو يحمل تمثالا صغيرا قدم له من
احد رواد المقهى يبدو بانها هي تلك
القنبله التي تسببت بالحادثه بحسب وسائل
اعلام روسيه
مصدر في قوات الامن لوكاله تاسك قال بان
قوه العبوه الناسفه تجاوزت 200 جرام من
ماده تي ان تي وبحسب منظم الحدث داخل
المقهى فان الاجراءات الامنيه الضعيفه
سمحت بوقوع التفجير لكن السر يكمن في
خفايا المقهى المتضرر من التفجير فهو مقهى
تعود ملكيته لقائد مجموعه فاجنر العسكريه
الروسيه حسب اعلام روسي
والابرز شخصيه الصحفي المستهدف فمقاطع
فيديو سابقه للمراسل الحربي المقتول يظهر
فيها وهو يردد عبارات تحريضيه
تشير الى انه مؤيد للعمليه العسكريه
الروسيه الا انه ينتقد استراتيجيه
الجنرالات في وزاره الدفاع كما يفعل قائده
مؤسس فاجنر
سنهزم الجميع وسنقتل الجميع وسنسلب كل من
يحتاج الى السرقه وسيكون كل شيء كما نحب
هيرو مقهى سام باتريس يعد ثاني اهم حادثه
بعد سابقه لها العام الماضي اودت بحياه
داريا دوجينا ابنه الكسندر دوجن الفيلسوف
الروسي المقرب من الرئيس بوتين في انفجار
سياره يشتبه بانها كانت ملغمه روان حمزه
العربيه
عام واحد على حادثه بوتشا المروعه حادثه
حادثه حصدت مئات المدنيين
ودمرت المدينه لكن جهود عادت الاعمار طوال
العام نقلت المدينه من حال الى اخر نتابع
توقفت المسارات جميعها تقطعت الطرق
والانفاس ايضا هنا قبل عام حدثت الكارثه
كارثه بوتشا راح ضحيتها مئات المدنيين
المدينه المنكوبه منذ ذلك التاريخ لم تقف
صامته بل صمدت وعادت الى الحياه اهالي
المدينه لم يكن امامهم الا ترمي مما خلفته
اثار الحرب
ليل النهار اليه الاعمار طوال العام لم
تهدا اعيد الاعمار لتعود سالمه الى ساكنها
مساعدات غربيه ساهمت في نقل المدينه من
حال الى اخر
هذا الجسر بمثابه ماوى للاشخاص الفرين من
بوتشا في اتجاه كييف واوشك العمال على
الانتهاء من ترميمه بجانبه اعاده اوكرانيا
بناء 120 جسرا مدمرا واصلحت مئه كيلو متر
من الطرق وانشات 330 ممرا مؤقتا وجده
الثمانين محطه سكه حديد لا سيما محطات
القطار ومستودعات القطارات
اعمال البناء حتى الان في بوتشا سددت من
الاحتياطات النقديه لاوكرانيا ومن مدفوعات
اوليه بقيمه 600 مليون دولار من بنك
الاستثمار الاوروبي
ما جرى في بوتشا تريده كييف ان يحدث في
كامل البلاد لكن التكلفه باهظه حيث يقدر
البنك الدولي تكلفه اعاده الاعمار في
اوكرانيا ب 411 مليار دولار غذاء السالم
العربيه
نشير الى العواجل التي وردتنا قبل قليل
مشاهدينا حيث قال السفير الروسي في
بيلاروسيا ان نشر الاسلحه النوويه
التكتيكيه سيتم في اقرب وقت ممكن وان
منشاه تخزين الاسلحه النوويه التكتيكيه
ستكتمل في يوليو المقبل
حقق زعيم الائتلاف الوطني الفنلندي
الفوزه بالانتخابات التشريعيه في هلسكني
خلفا لرئيسه الوزراء المنتهيه ولايتها
الاجتماعيه الديمقراطيه سان ماريين
اوبرو اعلن ايضا البدء في مفاوضات لتشكيل
حكومه اما من جانب رئيسه الوزراء سان
مارين فقد اعترفت بهزيمتها في الانتخابات
وحلت في المرتبه الثالثه بعد حزبي
الائتلاف الوطني واليميني المتطرف
[تصفيق]
فيو حقق المرشح ياكوب ميلاتو فيتش الفوز
في الانتخابات الرئاسيه بفارق كبير عن
منافسه ميلود وذلك رغما عن حادثه نسبيه في
السياسه وافادت تقديرات منظمه سيمي
المتخصصه في رصد عمليات الاقتراع افادت ان
ميلاتوفيتش حاز في الدوره الثانيه من
الانتخابات على نحو 60% من الاصوات مقابل
40% لمنافسه
بحث ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان والرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي
في جده بحث العلاقات الثنائيه الوثيقه
والتاريخيه بين البلدين الى جانب افاق
التعاون وسبل تعزيزه وتطويره في مختلف
المجالات كما ناقش الامير محمد بن سلمان
مع الرئيس المصري تطورات الاوضاع
الاقليميه والدوليه
مستمرون ونتابع
ترامب يدعو انصاره الى التبرع لحملته
الانتخابيه عشيه موعد محاكمته غدا في
نيويورك
حياكم الله من جديد تعتزموا الولايات
المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه واليابان بدا
مناورات بحريه مشتركه اليوم هي الاولى منذ
سبع سنوات وتشمل تدريبات البحث والانقاذ
المضاده للغواصات لمده يومين وذلك بمشاركه
حامله الطائرات يو اس اس ميميت الامريكيه
في مياه في المياه الدوليه جنوب جزيره
جيجو الجنوبيه وفق ما اعلنت وزاره دفاع
سول مؤكده ان التدريبات الثلاثيه تاتي
لتعزيز قدرات الاستجابه ضد التهديدات
لكوريا الشماليه تحت المياه بما في ذلك
الصواريخ الباليستيه التي تطلق من
الغواصات
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه ان الرئيس
الفرنسي ايمانويل سيزر بكين في الخامس من
ابريل الجاري في زياره تمتد الى ثلاثه
ايام حيث يلتقي ماكرون نظيره الصيني
شيجيبينغ وعددا من المسؤولين هذا من
المقرر ان يعقد او يعقد ماكرون اجتماعا
غدا مع رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه
قبل توجههما سويا الى الصين
تبدا اليوم في كوسوفو جلسه محاكمه رئيسها
السابق هاشم تقييف في محكمه خاصه في لاهاي
وذلك على خلفيه اتهامه بارتكاب جرائم حرب
ابان فتره انتفاضه عامي 1998
و199 وصل عددها الى عشره تهم بينها القتل
والتعذيب والاخفاء القصري
اظهرت استطلاعات راي اجرتها شركه ابسوس
المتخصصه في هذا الشان ان 45% من
الامريكيين عامه يرون ان رئيس البلاد
السابق يجب ان يواجه اتهامات بارتكاب
جريمه جريمه مضيفه الى ان
88% من الديمقراطيين ايد التحقيق مع تشرم
في منحاه في حين ان اغلب الجمهوريين
يعتقدون انه ما كان ينبغي توجيه الاتهام
وذلك بواقع 62%
[تصفيق]
وبينما ينتظر ملايين الامريكيين مثول
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب امام محكمه
نيويورك طلبت مؤيديها التبرع لحمله اعاده
انتخابه لعام 24 وذلك في بيان نشر على
موقع
قبل يومين فقط من الموعد المتوقع لتقديمه
للمحاكمه وقال ترامب في النص اذا كان
وضعكم سيئا كما حال الكثير منكم فلا
ترسلوا اي شيء واذا كان وضعكم جيدا والذي
اصبح ممكنا من خلال السياسات العظيمه
لاداره ارسلوا مساهماتكم الى حملتنا علينا
ان نستعيد بلادنا ونجعل امريكا عظيمه مره
اخرى
رده فعل الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب كانت حديثه من حوله فكيف كان وقع
لائحه الاتهام الجنائيه على ترامب
منهم من قال بان ترامب كان منزعجا وغاضبا
ومصدوما ومنهم من قال بانه ظل هادئا جدا
ورزينا وفقا لواشنطنبوست
الرئيس الامريكي السابق بحسب مصادر مقربه
تبلغ الخبر بمكالمه هاتفيه ثم بدا بالتحرك
اتصالات بالجمهوريين في الكونجرس ووعود
بالمحاربه حتى البراءه والدفع بالمظلوميه
الرئيس الامريكي السابق سيمثل امام محكمه
من هات يوم الثلاثاء القادم قبل ان يضطر
للوقوف امام قاض للاستماع الى التهم
الجنائيه الموجهه اليه تحت حمايه امنيه
مشدده وسط توقعات من احد مستشاريه بان
يظهر الرئيس السابق دقيقا وحذرا خاصه وان
هذه تعد سابقه سياسيه وتاريخيه قد يستفيد
منها ترامب كثيرا ويستغلها في حملته
الانتخابيه للعام 2024
عندما يسلم ترامب نفسه سيتم حجزه في
الغالب مثل اي شخص اخر يواجه التهم ستؤخذ
بصماته من دون تقييد يديه ربما وسيتمتع
بحمايه الخدمه السريه ومن شبه المؤكد انه
سيطلق سراحه في اليوم نفسه
الفريق القانوني الترامب وفريق حملته
امضوا اسابيع في التحضير لصدور لائحه
الاتهام ضده بحثوا خلالها خطه الهجوم
باستخدام ورقه الدوافع السياسيه ضد مدعي
عام مقاطعه منهات ومحاميه السابق وهو احد
الشهود الرئيسيين في القضيه
ونداءات لجمع التبرعات والحلفاء
القانونيين والسياسيين والاعلاميين
[تصفيق]
كتساعمال الاغاثه جهودهم في اركنسا
الامريكيه التي تضررت بشده جراء الاعاصير
التي ضربت الولايه ارتفع عدد القتلى من
الاعاصير التي اجتاحت اجزاء من الغرب
الاوسط في الولايه الى 32 على الاقل وتجمع
المتطوعون في الكنائس والمراكز الخيريه في
عاصمه الولايه لتل راك لاعداد الطعام
وتعبئته ليتم توزيعه من قبل جيش الانقاذ
ومجموعات الاغاثه الاخرى للاشخاص الذين
تضرروا جراء الاعصار العنيف
افاد مركز رصد الزلزال المتوسطي ان زلزالا
ضرب بقوه 6.6 درجه على مقياس ريختر قرب
الساحل الشرقي لشبه جزيره كما تشادكا
الروسيه وبعمق 100 كلم كما افاد نظام
التحذير من تسونامي في الولايات المتحده
انه لم يكن هناك تحذير من تسونامي بعد
وقوع الزلزال
من احياء الحجاز والشام الى خنادق الرصاص
والموت خلال الحرب العالميه الاولى يتناول
مسلسل سفر برلك ما ارتكبته الدوله
العثمانيه بحق اهل شبه الجزيره العربيه
والتجنيد الالزامي للشبان العرب دراما
اجتماعيه تاريخيه لا يجب عنها الطابع
الرومانسي ضمن القصه اخر مشروع حضر له
المخرج الراحل حاتم علي قبيله وفاته وهو
من اخراج الليث حجه البطوله توزعت بين
نجوم من السعوديه وسوريا ولبنان والعالم
العربي المزيد في التقرير في تقرير
الدراما مع سهى الواعل واعداد ايام القاسم
[موسيقى]
المريض
الكل مجتمع يبغى يسقط دوله الاسلام بعد
نهوضها
[موسيقى]
مرحبا
مؤلمه بعد مئه عام هذا هو مسلسل سفر اللي
كان مفاجاه الموسم الدرامي رمضانى الضخمه
عن كارثه التهجير الجماعي اللي طبقتها
الدوله العثمانيه عام
1915 تجاه الالاف من الرجال والنساء
والاطفال من سكان المدينه المنوره حدث
تاريخي كان من المهم جدا للدراما ان
تتناولوا يوما هذا حدث
قيمته التاريخيه وايضا قيمته الانسانيه
ويعتبر اليوم وكانه جريمه حرب لانه تم
تهجيرها للمدينه حتى قيل في كثير من
المصادر التاريخيه انه لم يبقى الا 41 شخص
من اهالي المدينه
يقتلون المدينه المنوره تم تهجيرا بالكامل
هو رفاق دراسه الجامعيه في اسط السوري
يحيى واللبنانيين فايز وفريد حيث يخوض
الاصدقاء الاربعه رحله الوعي السياسي
والانتقال من اروقه التحصيل العلمي الى
جبهات القتال مع الجيش العثماني اولا في
معارك البلقان على الحدود الروسيه ومن ثم
التمرد على ظلم السلطنه العثمانيه ووحشيه
ممارساتها انا فعلا
حسن في اسطنبول الابنيه التفاصيل
الديكورات المحلات اللبس المترو العربيات
الحنطور تفاصيل التفاصيل التفاصيل جدا
كلها موجوده وكلها موضوعه بعنايه لدرجه
انه فعليا الواحد فينا بيصدقني اسطنبول
كان كان شيء كثير كبير لالنا
بالارز لما صورنا على حدود البلقان كان
كمان شي كتير حلو لانه عبد الرحمن مثلا
كثير كان بالنسبه له ثلج كثير كبير وكثير
كان الجو حلو هنيك وما حسينا حالنا يعني
انه افترقنا هلا كتير اشتقنا للسات هون
كمان بس مره كان كمان كانت مغامره لقلنا
انا وعبد الرحمن ويحيى
الجمهور فعلوا مع العمل باهتمام كبير هنا
بعد التغريدات
[موسيقى]
اذا كان مكتوب على اهل ذي البلاد انهم
يحاربون
هل هم اولى في جهادهم ودمهم
الى العناوين
اسرائيل ترفعوا حاله التاهب على الحدود
الشماليه بعد اسقاط مسيره يعتقد بانها
ايرانيه
بعد رفع العلم على مبنى اداره بخموت
اوكرانيا تؤكد انها ما زالت تسيطر على
المدينه
لاول مره منذ سبع سنوات تدريبات كوريه
جنوبيه امريكيه يابانيه لمواجهه تهديدات
في امان الله
[موسيقى]